Today we're going to be playing Mugenics.
It's a game I've been wanting to try out for a very, very
long time.
Well, I mean, it came out like two weeks ago.
The entire two weeks I've been wanting to play this game.
Oh my god.
The longest two weeks of my life.
I heard a lot of positive things about Mugenics.
Also, I feel like dad is way too tall.
I'm sorry, dad.
You're way too tall on the screen.
I gotta kick you up.
out.
I got a little too tall.
Let's see.
Um, well, sorry.
Get out.
It's Mugenics time.
Cats only.
I'm sorry, Dad.
This is a cats only lobby.
Anyway, um, it is a genre that I usually do not like playing
and it's a, was a tactical turn-based, uh, roguelike and I'm
not very good with tactical stuff.
So, but I have heard a lot of really good things about this
game.
I heard it's very addicting.
Most likely we will never complete this game because I heard
someone chat was like, this game is 250 hours long.
I'm like, ha ha ha ha.
All right.
This might be a good one-off game.
Maybe something I might play on Twitch later on in the
future.
Who knows?
Yeah, apparently it is.
It's by the creators.
It's by the creators of Binding of Isaac.
And they've been working on this game.
For a very, very long time.
I believe, like...
I know it's like...
6 plus years, right?
They've been working on it for a long time.
The craziest shit is that...
What's his name?
I think...
And this is the craziest fun fact.
But Chris Chan is in this game.
Apparently, you have the potential to breed a...
Sonic 2 in Mugenics and it is voice acted by the Chris Chan.
So that's very interesting.
That's yeah.
And obviously the cats that you get is RNG.
You cannot sadly, the one thing that I felt was can confirm
it is real.
Unfortunately, the only thing that I will say is a huge con
for me for this game is that you cannot change the names of
the cats.
So the cats can come from your friends list.
It can come from the database, but you cannot change the
cat's names.
They have a lot of cat names in there and a lot of cats that
you can get.
rename the cat they were born with that name it's their
chosen name um we beg emin enough maybe we can get vtuber
voices for the next dlc thank you the super chat doctor
thank you thank you anyway anyway let's try out mugenics uh
the best thing i heard about this game is is the is the
inbreeding i mean the breeding the breed
Anyway, I heard the soundtrack was really good, guys.
You, Genics.
All right, let me know the sound is okay.
Apparently, the intro, there's like 250 variations of the
intro.
It's like the Simpsons intro.
So, sound guy, if you are here, I would need to know.
I would need to know if the sound is okay.
So, yes, you can...
Breed your cats.
It's all about...
Oh, meow.
What is that?
So, one of those meows could have been Chris Chan.
I'm just saying.
One of those meows could have been...
What's normal, safe, random?
Alright, I mean normal.
We're not fucking pussies.
We're not prudes here.
We got the birds and the bees talk.
Alright.
Uh...
Video settings.
Okay, maybe it was not uncapped.
I don't think I need that many frames to watch two cats
bang.
I, I, I, I'm pretty sure I'm fine.
Meow, meow.
What do you mean?
It's all cats.
It's random.
All right, we'll do random.
All right, well, we'll do random.
Apparently random is very funny.
There's some funny ones.
All right, all right.
we'll do random then um what is the it's so sad to see my oh
she gave up on love and become a crazy cat lady so i know
right we don't think i'd be the crazy weiner dog lady uh
it's crazy i can't believe it your bets on the betting
website failed yet again you guys okay it's actually insane
that people are actually like betting random things now on
those like betting websites um i don't know Like, because,
like, everybody would bet on, like, there's so many betting
websites for so many random things now.
There's one for the Super Bowl where, like, I read a tweet
about how somebody bet on the Super Bowl that someone was
going to start, like, running on the field.
And then, yeah, prediction records.
So, like, and then, and then, obviously, during the Super
Bowl, nobody was running on the fields.
So, he, like, instead, he, like, went on the field himself
and started running in it.
And then he earned like $200,000 from the prediction he
made.
And then got five to $1,000.
Yeah.
Yeah, 10K that he's going to cop three times the stream.
Yeah, apparently like people are like betting on like,
betting on like random things now.
But yes, it's that crazy.
You lost the bet.
I wasn't going to...
I became a crazy cat lady instead of the crazy weird.
dog lady.
Oh, he lost it because he talked so fucking that guy is so
goddamn stupid.
Why would you tell anyone?
He's like, yeah, I cheese the system.
Anyway, cops, here's my hat.
You can handcuff me right now.
That's crazy.
Why would you tell anyone?
You're like, yeah, I found the loophole.
Anyway, cops, my address is bumped up and here's my zip code
too.
And my address as well if you want it he did it for him the
love of the game now he's like in jail and like now he lost
his lost 200k and got fine a thousand dollars at the super
bowl also sound do we have any sound guys alive do we have
any yeah you admit to cheating when the statues of
Limitations are over.
That's what I did.
Oh, hey.
Alright.
There's my cat.
Science!
Scared you, didn't I?
I don't know how scary a buzzword like science can be these
days.
But trust me when I say science can actually be a good thing
sometimes.
Take this table, for instance.
A science made this table and the floor it sits on.
There are even people there who believe that a science made
you and I.
But I digress.
The point I was trying to make here is that cats are a
science too.
A science that I, Thomas A.
Venus, invented.
Wait, was the artwork also made by one guy?
Because it's the by-new Isaac.
Art style or is it a team of artists that just...
copy the art style but what do you have to do with all of
this well word on the street is you're a bit of
felineologist yourself i know you just we just met by bet if
you and i put our brains to get beans to get brains to get
it we could actually change the world it's one guy that's
crazy i heard like he made back his entire budget for this
game in like three hours oh he had a team okay uh oh That's
cool for Isaac Fanners.
That's cool.
Yeah, then they could follow like the The artwork style what
is it called like the you know how every every animation has
like a like a Bible of like for like the style the artwork?
Oh, there's like a specific word for it.
I'm sorry.
I'm like getting off track But anime is called an animation
Bible where you have to follow like specific guidelines on
how the artwork's supposed to look like and then My favorite
one is the king of the hill one where you're supposed to not
make a not make the wife sexy uh yeah the style yeah the
pitch bible i don't know if guys ever seen the king of the
hill pitch bible where they're like please do not make her
too sexy
i'm sorry i'm like a bit off top i have to show you guys
what's what's her name what's the white king of the hill
wife uh wife's name yeah it's the style guide is it actually
called style guide No, I'm not talking about model sheets.
There's like a, it's like a Peggy.
Okay, wait.
Let me see if I can find it.
There you go.
Don't draw Peggy.
Let me, let me show you this.
It's like one of the style, like animation Bible.
Here.
Don't draw Peggy too shapely.
Well, I'll even show it on stream.
So they're like, don't make her too sexy, guys, because
that's not part of the style.
King of the hell.
It's like the animator guide.
Because they have to be like on...
What's the word for it?
Like on model or some shit.
That's the problem with...
I think a lot of people complain about Steven Universe.
Because like they're never on model.
Same with the new Powerpuff Girls reboot.
They were never like on model.
And people were always complaining about it.
Because they never...
They never looked like the characters.
Like they were like super inconsistent.
They were like off model and everything.
If you get ugly cats, you can...
I...
We live with our ugliness.
Anyway, here's a little fun fact.
Don't draw Peggy too shapely.
That's sexy Peggy.
And that's animators drink.
Yes, no.
We live with our...
God gave us ugly cats.
So we gotta live with it.
Like, we start if the cats aren't ugly enough.
Alright, now take a gander at these fine specimens.
This is my latest batch.
Straight out of their bio vats.
Choose to a boy and a girl.
Trust me, you'll find out why later.
Meow.
Oh my god, I love his butt head.
I like how I heard meow.
Okay, I'm going to do a gamby.
all right i assume these two are boys i like mr beth um yeah
i like oh my god but the butt head though dokey versus draco
stream dokey all right thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you oh my god mr bamboo i'm sorry mr butthead i i
i was tempted what's wrong with you wow okay i didn't expect
me to pass on the best of the bunch whatever their pieces
will be put to use you can't if your baby is ugly you can't
just re-roll the baby guys we gotta live with it in fact i
think with my brain technically you can but then it's not
accepted in society um we do have orphanages for a reason in
fact i think uh i think with my brains and your ability to
choose less than ideal cats we could really things up hell
enough cats i bet we could reverse time maybe even make
dying impossible ania's a nuke radioactive blood a bit of
elbow grease don't worry i'll be sure to harvest some from
you's elbows before she's incinerated oh oh oh so that's
what happened you know it's her fault for being born too
ugly uh it's it's not my fault i let you guys vote.
You let this happen, guys.
I was gonna save her.
I was gonna save her, guys.
You let this happen.
Go into the world and hoard some cats.
That's not... Her blood is on your hands.
You wasn't ugly enough.
I asked you guys your opinion.
I let you vote.
Click here.
He kicked you out?
Yeah, he does that.
Names butch, even though I could give a frick if you live or
die.
I can't help but see a bit of myself in you.
If you get what I mean, you want to survive in Boon County,
you're going to need to learn how to fight.
So listen up.
This is your team.
These are your enemies.
Your goal is to kill them all.
Alright, battle is now Gambo's turn.
above Gambo's head.
This is Gambo's basic attack.
It's melee range, so you'll need to move next to the rat to
hit it.
This is your movement action.
You can move once.
Okay, there you go.
The tactical part of the game.
Click it.
And then click the tile you want to move.
Okay.
Move.
Alright, get next to that rat.
Now that you're next to the rat, you can attack it.
Oh, okay.
I can attack on the same move of my movement.
Click attack and then Click the rat.
Bam!
Bye, rat.
Sweet.
You really destroyed that bastard.
Did you not notice that you got a buff when you killed that
thing?
It's because of that passive ability.
Hover over to learn what it does.
You can also hover over your cat to learn what that buff
does, too.
Okay.
Here's a ram stat when you're down a unit.
Nice.
She's very self-assured.
There are also spells.
You only have one so far.
Unfortunately, you lack the mana to cast it.
It's how much mana the spell costs.
It's down.
good so far guys is how much mana you have you gain mana at
the end of your turn equal to your light bulb there's
nothing left to do so end your turn what about him oh i
guess it ends his turn is now mr bamboo's turn a little
quiet sound guy what's your opinion
do you agree with that dragon okay he has a range while
selecting where to move to you can see a preview of your
basic attack range in red moving range to tackle are as
close as you can get all right oh okay so like this is the
range of holy that's a big ass cat unfortunately you're
still not in range to attack the tom tom um however you do
have it if he the sound guy doesn't agree bad you have to
cast one of your spells take a look at roll here roll only
costs and you have five all right cool click roll and then
roll closer that thing all right there i'll roll here
because it's closer then you should already know how to do
that attack all right cool what did he do oh is that a
furball god fucking gross okay this is also why i like i i
have a dog instead of a cat i i have a fear of like when i
like a furballs it's like because dogs don't do Like, I
don't know, if I have a cat, and then, like, it just
randomly starts spitting furballs, and you just find it in
random places in your home.
That Tom Thomas pre-stick covers, so he'll take a few more
hits to kill it.
All right.
And turn.
Wait, can I?
Okay, I'll turn up the odd music.
Well, it's already up, by the way.
Yeah, but, like, dogs don't normally vomit.
Unless you, unless he ate something bad.
It's not a normal occurrence that you're going to...
to have yeah he just only has a crippling back problem but
that's fixable it just needs like ten thousand dollars but
it's it's fixable it's fixable purples are not fixable it's
a way of life okay it's gambus turning in you not enough
magic to cast your spell spit he also has allergy yes but
like that's just a way of life all right spit on him minus
one that was not good spitting you can cast spells as many
times per term as you want as long as you have the mana so
spit again make it real thick now all right do it again uh
good job at this it's just inconvenient The furball is very
inconvenient.
I trust that you can finish the rest of your fight on your
own.
So I'm going to hide in those bushes and judge you from
afar.
Good luck.
Alright.
We're making move a little closer.
And then be like, oh, I moved wrong.
Ooh, that's awkward.
Never mind.
Meow.
Alright.
uh just use that yeah and then i'll roll away now oh he's
still coming after me meow meow all right keep spitting nice
all right get get a little closer and then smack that ass
yeah
She did it!
Beginner's luck.
Okay, now listen.
Each time you finish combat, one of your cats is going to
level up.
Check out old Mr. Bamboo.
He's about to get a whole lot better.
Let's just look at all these options.
Originally, I was going to let you choose yourself by
feeling you need to point something out.
There's a pretty awesome combo here.
Check out Mr. Bamboo's current pass effect.
Okay.
Burn you inflict and... Oh, so I should get a burn.
So I should get Sunburn.
Right?
Now read what Sunburn does.
Okay.
Makes burn more So take sunburn already or not it's your
funeral, but then he can poop at it.
Wait, what do I do with poop though?
I feel like I should get Sunburn but then he can also poop
you guys might not see it, but it says dump and he poops
there But I don't know what poop does, but fuck.
Okay, I'll trust him I'll trust this random thief.
He'll never lie to me Okay, but remember every cat is
different.
So always check out what your cat's passive ability does A
cat's passive can make or break or run And combos, wins,
games Always be on lookout for abilities that combo Alright,
how do I heal Mr. Burt?
Oh, sorry, Mr. Bamboo I wish I could rename my cats I really
do I need to be really, I could name the cats after you guys
And then recycle them I can make you guys Breed
It's a lost Opportunity, that's all I'm gonna say We know
Toki Toki no I can breed the dragons I was just They missed
a shot there Lost opportunity Bunch blocks your path To use
brown Braun or brains to get past him Check your stats to
see the Okay oh Braun Apparently I'm really smart Uh
All right.
Yay.
Mr. Bamboo points cleverly behind Butch, distracting him.
Well, hello, Mr. FastPass.
You're lucky your smartness is so high.
You'd be chewing rocks.
Yay.
Next, you think you've been a super chat?
Thank you.
All right, next stop.
Oh, look.
I got a steak.
Yay!
What does the stick do?
A minute attack.
Oh.
Okay, yeah, I think.
Oh my god.
Dean 7 mine.
Oh, okay.
We don't need to use that.
Hold up.
You don't want to go to this boss fight.
I'm prepared.
You have items that you're not yet equipped to catch.
Click here to equip them first.
I gave them a stick.
I mean, I guess I'll give him mana.
Give him some little cat nip.
It won't hurt anybody.
Just a small dose.
You know?
I'm like, you know, just a little micro dosing for the cat.
Alright, pebbles!
Holy shit!
Back, back!
Alright, is the sound a lot better now?
It's time, yeah, just a small hit, you know?
And then, like, if they take breaks in between, then, like,
they'll never get addicted.
Never get hooked.
I train pebbles here myself.
He's about to rock your world.
Show me what you got.
Oh, awesome.
One last tip before I leave it up to you.
Attack from behind to do more damage.
Oh, I did that.
Oh, my God.
Pebbles.
Pebbles is a little scary.
Not gonna lie.
Pebbles is a little scary, guys.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, me out.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, we'll grab the cat in the back.
before he fucking dies.
And then...
That foot!
Alright, and then we roll away.
And he rolled away.
Meow, meow.
Okay.
Hey, so you might have noticed this already, but take a look
up here.
This is the order you and your enemies take their turns.
Okay.
The turn order is usually the same every round, so pay
attention to it.
Or don't.
Cat fight, cat.
Why are you still?
Okay, it's fine.
All right, okay, that's fine.
Meow.
I was gonna say, why the fuck are you still, like, there?
Wait.
Um.
Cat fight, cat fight.
Cat fight.
That's it.
I'm going to go next to you.
Poke.
Stick.
Bam.
And I'll keep spinning.
And then I'll spit again!
And then I'll spit...
Oh, I can't spit.
Oh, I...
I...
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, he is not fine.
Oh, no.
Okay, I can still sunburn him.
Get sunburned!
And then...
Move here.
Oh, my God.
I'm still too far.
Okay, I'll roll...
Here.
Okay.
There.
Alright.
Mr. Bamboo might be fucked, guys.
Mr. Bamboo does not look very healthy.
I think Mr. Bamboo might die.
There's a chance.
Oh, unless...
Oh, my God.
There you go.
It's okay.
Mr. Bamboo, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
Cat foot.
Cat.
Cat's foot.
Alright.
There you go.
Sick!
Oh, if I spit on him, it'll get rid of the... It's fine.
Alright, one.
One hit.
And then...
Mr. Bamboo, please.
You can do this.
Just take... Just take one more hit.
Just take...
Oh!
Well, damn.
It looks like...
Okay, nobody's living that.
Look.
Gotta hit three.
It's okay.
Just a little.
He's twitching.
He's alive.
My cat.
And if they get injured and one of their stats get reduced
permanently.
Don't let their body hit too many times.
Or they will actually die.
It's okay.
He's twitching.
He's still alive.
He's just... He's you know.
He's...
He's not the same as he was before.
You know.
Sometimes he stands there for like 20 seconds longer than he
should.
But... And he's forgot he doesn't know what two plus two is
anymore but he's alive sometimes he stares in the distance
uh for a few hours or so before uh before he he realizes
that you know we've been calling him for five hours but but
he's alive he's alive just little brain damage doesn't hurt
nobody uh as long as your other cats can finish but your
down cat will still survive so the fight don't yet think
he's gonna need a wheelchair no no he's okay i still have oh
there we go i told you he's okay like
you know it's okay guys like mr bamboo lives all right what
do i have i have split attack with infinity is one damage
attack kill and Jason inflict burn game spawn a poop okay
what does poop do what does poop do guys cat foot cat foot
it poops okay let's just grab poop I don't I want to know
what poop does congrats you did good out there it just poops
this marks the end of your first little adventure it's time
to go home You'll bring back any food, coins, items,
treasure, and juries you gain during the journey.
These supplies will hopefully prove you.
Swilt you at some point.
Oh, and yet, ever want to save an exit run?
Just click on that thing.
Bye.
All right.
It tastes really bad.
Thank you.
I hope...
Oh, my God.
Let's head to that house on my good friend, Mr. Bamboo.
He wasn't the same since he took a boulder on his head, but
he's still my best friend.
It's me, Mr. Tinkles.
You know that I heard about me around town.
Yes, and all the rumors are true.
I spread them myself.
Just like my legs.
Oh, Mr. Tinkles.
What?
This is so 2010 humor.
I'm sorry.
You can tell this was written around 2010 to 2015.
God, I'm so bad.
Anyway, you can call me Tink.
My God, look at this.
these kittens they just returned home from an adventure and
they look busted cats that have already been on adventure
are retired that means they won't be going on any more
adventures oh so after each run my cats just they're one and
done that's it so why don't you take these guys inside so
did you just retire i mean that's the life i didn't realize
I didn't realize.
Mr. Bamboo still has a couple of lives in him.
Look at him.
I mean, don't look at him too hard.
But I feel like they still have a couple of runs in them.
They're one.
One pumping done.
Well, they seem pretty comfortable, I guess.
Stop shaking him.
So you can...
He's brain damaged, not physically impaired.
He's still going.
Like you can still be a tank So you can now It's mental
damage You now end the day and watch what Yeah he has nine
lives for Okay well eight lives to be fair He has eight
lives for a reason Yeah he can still Fight guys When lights
go off When you end the day every cow will eat one food So
make sure you always have morning love Is he so fine Wow Get
sad.
Oh shit.
I caught him What oh shit I also got him there don't worry I
caught him What is this?
This is the stats I guess What I caught him?
What the fuck is like Mr. Bav there we go oh they kissed
without they kissed without without protection we all know
you gotta put a napkin in between the lips if you don't want
to get pregnant guys and made a kid in oh he looks like just
like your dad pre-marital kisses I forgot to marry my cats
guys
all right oh my what an eventful night don't tell my wife
about what he has a wife i did not expect that he did not
seem a very wife type of guy oh you have a new kitten you'll
need to grow up before you can go on an adventure though
don't worry um there's something in the wire here that makes
them grow up in like one day also look a stray cat has come
to your house looking for your toks take them inside right
oh here you go i got zero x's once you have made enough kins
or collect enough strays you can take them out on adventure
to find more supplies you want four fresh kins to send out
an adventure but you don't have enough yet so like just keep
ending the day and collecting strays until you do all right
also you can right click the kins see if they inherit
anything from his parents and check his stats oh look
there's poop all right doc what is their speed.
They can roll and they can... Wait, what's the point?
I let... I gave him or the ability to poop and then I can't
even use it.
Okay, they can melee and ship with a unit.
Okay, they're both smart cats.
That's good.
Where's the water?
I was supposed to...
Oh, will they just level up tomorrow?
I guess they'll level up.
Wait, what's so bad?
What's bad about my cats?
They're okay.
Like... Oh.
Oh my gosh, look at this cat.
Oh, she landed on her feet.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, oops, alright.
How about you?
Meow.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, wait, she grew up.
Meow.
It's okay, they're fine.
I want to know that land on their feet.
I just wanted to know if they'll land on their feet, you
know?
I never had a cat before.
I was testing out the theory.
Stop, they are not getting hurt, guys.
They have nine lives.
Acer, they give us a reach out.
Thank you.
I'm out of control.
Open up.
It's science.
That's what he said.
I'm just I'm just conducting science.
It's the love of the game First thing those cats make babies
and become astronauts with the centrifuge training Someone
caught PETA.
Wait, that's where it's carry on, Doki Are the adults?
Yeah, so how do I so do I have a choice on who they bang or
like Do I get a choice or oh hey, I have a ristocat him he's
so fancy it's random oh yeah free will that's not fun i
should have a choice on who they bang what if like there's
like characteristics i want what's it called it's it's just
it's eugenics it's okay sorry it's mugenics that's the whole
premise of mugenics it's selective breeding
Okay, that's good.
I was like, that destroys the whole point of eugenics if I
can't select the people they breed with.
The night was calm.
Nothing of significance occurred.
Oh, yay.
Evil has me.
What do you mean?
It's for science.
Oh, yay.
With that new strain there, you should have enough cats to
go on another adventure yeah and get ready for a journey all
right meow me meow bro keep acting like that crazy kid
sitting towards her bubble cats and stuff solid thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you meow all right let's
see what are your characteristics gain lava shot okay you
seem strong all right and then we'll grab the kid too and
then we'll grab we'll grab you and we'll grab you we got
four there you go let's depart that's how the modern bug
came to be the bottom nations they are brady thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you um thank you there's a
very helpful guy to select the freedom i recommend reading
it's called dune thank you the super chat osni thank you
thank you yeah but we dogs because of selective breeding all
right there we go um so it's not all bad it's not it's not
all that bad i mean their spines are really fucked up but
like they're really cute though and they're not that yeah
but they're really cute all right punch your way to victory
who's a strong strongest um we'll give you the fight the
actually yes uh we'll give you that and then who's the
weakest oh you get the archery and then who has the magic
becomes a rat random becomes a random um okay you obviously
you can be the tank um and then You grab, you can be the
mage.
Whoever be a father.
Oh, he's neutered.
No, he, if he does become a father, then like, I wasted a
lot of money to get those balls chopped.
I also want to know where the fuck the balls, where the,
where the fuck the, the, the mini dads were located because
he has no balls.
Um, thank you for the super chat, Koto.
Thank you.
Like, I want to know where he's hiding them because from
what I saw, there are no balls in there.
Alright, um...
I'll give you this.
You're the fighter.
Me, yeah!
And also the P, because the P stored in the balls.
Let's go.
Embark upon the adventure.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure I did.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Use a melee tower.
Oh, wait.
That's better.
And then we'll give the tank the stick.
all right here we go let's move on to the city battles start
oh there's a kitten let's beat up children in game okay
there's a pooter
um deal dashboard then made attack with ship swap positions
forces an enemy to focus on you i feel that Okay, we can
kill him.
And then poke the kid in with the stick.
Yeah, that's right.
Run!
That's like you're right.
Oh, wait.
Can I grab the coins?
Knock back.
Heavy-handed.
Goad.
I'll goad this one.
Come on.
Get over.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
And then...
Oh, I can go to get...
I'll end my turn here.
Magic...
Art.
Okay, I can't use that.
Game plus Fire Blast.
Can I use that?
No.
Uh, alright, I'll move here then.
Um, grab this.
What the?
Okay, I'm definitely not gunned.
You're not passing down your generation.
Alright, me now.
Alright, get over here.
Smack that cat.
Or smack.
smack that little pooter is he dead I can't tell I hop up
the two tiles hop over here grab that coin that one dollar
right okay whatever and turn meow meow okay we're gonna
we'll go here and then we'll lob looking right.
Get out of here.
And then we'll end our turn.
Oh, tall grass.
Give a chance to dodge.
Oh, that's good to know.
Minus five?
Holy shit, that's a lot of damage.
Get out of here!
That's right.
Give me your money, too.
We'll shift with...
I cannot...
Wait.
Swap positions with an adjacent unit.
Oh, I can't swap it now.
Okay, I'll go I'll go this one.
Meow.
Alright, enter.
Okay, we'll move here.
Get you out of here.
Get you out of here, too.
That's fucking right.
Enter.
I want to grab this, whatever this is.
Can I grab the poop?
Guys?
uh problem think of a super chat thank you thank you um i
think you have a pro tip what uh guemann thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you what's in the poop guys is
there anything in the poop i'm gonna hit it oh oops
it's fine i'll just do that real quick uh
Maybe they'll have treasures.
Yeah, I was thinking that.
Ow.
Meow.
Let's roll here.
Oh, shit.
No, I couldn't get the poop.
What do I have to go to settings for?
Well, why do you want me to go to settings?
But what I'm thinking of, Super Chat, Thank you, thank you.
So when's the mob that replaced the sprites with Dragoo?
Is that even a super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Um.
Dude, your death perception can't be this bad.
Please say psych.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Oh, there's that.
Wait, why did that guy told me to go to the settings?
Is there, is there something I should look at?
Game plus one.
Spawn a maggot familiar?
Wait, set a trap?
Did not do it.
What did I do with my fighter?
Oh, double.
Oh, no, I don't need it.
I don't need double confirm.
Guys, that's a rivals thing.
I don't need double confirm for this.
One or two.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Getting a bonus attack at the start.
Oh, wait, that's so good.
I'll do a bonus attack.
All right, what do I have?
He has 12 HP.
Who is fucked up the most?
Oh, he's fine.
He's fine.
Uh, found a severed headlight.
I'm blinking outside.
What should we do?
Examine, destroy, eat.
We should eat him.
Can't be that bad.
It's good food.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh no.
oh oh no no look i thought it'd be okay i looked very it
looked eatable how is i supposed to know it would be that
bad all right balasai puter oh hey these are like the isaac
enemies fucked up am i i mean it's not it's all right it's
not that bad i'm not that fucked up
i'll smash him and then i'm gonna grab some money real quick
and i'll end my turn uh i'll move yeah i'll smash him and
then I'm gonna go you get over here bitch that's right and
I'll end my turn and then you use my magic and then I'm
gonna go here and fireball that's right and I'll end my turn
me meow alright let me move up here I should be able to lob
this Holy shit That's a good ass move See I told you It's
okay Wait that has Spawns random pickups when Okay yeah It's
gonna take a while to hit this
Yeah it's gonna take a while to hit this I don't know I'm
gonna hit the poop I'm just gonna smack the poop Yay, one
dollar.
Grab this.
Smack the poop.
Oh, the poop, the money is in the fire.
That's not great.
We'll go to him.
And then, that's fine.
She can tank this.
And then, we'll use magic for that.
we're gonna I'm very tempted to grab the money oh wait I can
okay he's gonna hurt him I'll just fireball him and I'll
enter she's immune to fire I remember
I had a shot that spawns brambles in an area oh wait an
extra turn um I'll just I'll just go here and maybe I can
lot of this yeah yeah easy oh my god i'm a natural at this
game
uh yay got plus one strength okay jump to an open tower
within range you and each i like cat game plus two shield oh
wait give a unit plus four and compute spawner cooked me on
pick i assume that's HP, right?
Open towel of enraged and inflict bruise on all adjacent
units.
You know what?
Let's do...
Wait, one or two, chat, which is better.
Or three.
The last one is barbecue, but I don't think that's...
I don't think we need it.
Okay, I don't think enrage is gonna be smart.
I like one and four.
I'm gonna do leap then.
all right grab that chest what's in it oh spare parts what
can i do with that spawn a scrap pickup where you move from
okay i won't give the the guy with the broken ribs this all
right we'll give it to you we'll give it to the tank i
believe in the tank okay why are you the first one again but
the cat's how as it burns them all right oh wait what what
did that do i can't seem okay wait they seem okay it's fine
oh check top right i didn't check top right oh it's oh it's
point oh never mind it's not okay it's no not never mind
guys no longer okay oh i didn't realize it affects like the
battlefield i realized that's what it meant should be fine
right but
all right right here in the center of it all that's fine
i'll end my turn here charlie's not gonna all right it's
just another trap that's okay um We're gonna go here.
Oh, hey, there's a spare part.
And then we'll end our turn.
Wait.
The trap's gone.
Oh.
Okay, here, here, and here.
Okay, I just noticed the trap's gone.
I thought...
Just...
Oh.
Oh, no.
Guys, I already forgot where it spawned, guys.
all right okay oh no where else okay here okay okay oh shit
okay it's fine oh no wait where is it where is it um yeah
okay there's a trap here so that means this is safe okay
nice i knew it i'm so smart i should be safe here all right
we're all taking damage that's good Oh, no, there's a trap
here now, too.
Okay, there's no trap here, though.
There's no trap.
There's a trap here.
Oh, my God.
Okay, there's here.
And then...
And then we hop here.
We smack you!
That's right!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's okay.
I dodged all the traps.
Okay, now he's stuck there, I guess.
For the rest of his life.
um well i guess he's now stuck here for the rest of his life
now okay and then we'll go with him yeah meow that's right
and then we punch you and uh well i guess i'll end turned
out oh god oh god okay there's a trap here all right that's
fine because from what i remembered it's fine i will fire
blast bam and then magic and fire blast again and then we're
fine that's right oh okay
all right i'll shoot a bramble here i don't know what that's
gonna do okay well that was pretty much useless and i i
already don't know where all the traps are so i assume
yeah my assumption was wrong my assumption was wrong yay
you know one bear trap guys only one bear trap i call that a
win at that point all right shoot knock back each shoot
spawn a poop cast a fire that inflicts burn to slow to and
on all units around you.
Okay.
Shoot a lane ball that deals and knocks the unit hits three
tiles in there.
I feel like...
Yeah, the ring kills the boss.
Yay!
I feel like three.
I'm gonna do three.
Freezer burn.
Wait, hard.
How hard is hard?
Oh, I can't even go.
Oh, it's like hard.
I can't even go there.
It's locked for me.
No!
That's my tank.
Why are they all so clumsy?
You're doing so much better than the few people I watch.
Congrats, Alice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay.
I don't know what I'm...
Look at that.
I mean, of course I know what I'm doing, guys.
I'm just using my big-ass brain.
Alright.
Get over there.
Of course I know what I'm doing.
Meow.
Alright, let's just...
I'll grab this money.
Is that a child?
Alright, nice.
I burned him.
That was a child.
Alright, roll over here.
We hop here.
And then we can't smack it.
We'll just look at it.
And turn.
Dash!
What the Fuck!
Holy shit.
That could have given me rabies.
I was just gonna lob it here.
That's like, Sianara, right?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
No, my broken leg!
Okay, it's dead.
It's dead.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
It's dead, though.
He's fine, Right?
Yeah, he's fine.
And I'll goad him over.
Meow, meow.
Oh, he's hiding like a little bitch.
Get over here.
That's sucking, right?
Get closer.
My leg!
Alright.
Uh.
Holy shit.
Okay, that does too much.
Meow.
I'll just walk over here.
Okay, he's still alive.
I mean, I can literally just heat it up.
Yeah, I'm gonna say.
Alright, that's okay.
I have heals.
Yay!
Alright, he's now level two.
Gore!
Dash three tiles, damage inflict bruise, and throw what you
hit towards your original tile.
Rock toss.
Earthquake.
Has a chance.
Dispel.
Damage in a cone with a 10.
Oh, I feel like Earthquake is going crazy.
I don't go with Earthquake.
Okay, we gotta heal one of these cats.
What's this?
Paper shoulder pads.
Okay, that should go to my tank.
Your basic attack inflicts.
Alright, yeah, we're gonna give that to you.
And then you need HP.
You go eat that.
all right you are smart enough a small fetus floats before
chair caro with an inquisit look on his face this inky black
figure feels familiar somehow oh it's from binding of Isaac
all right talk to it yay oh my god okay my cat grew a tumor
but that's okay it's a good tumor I didn't know that existed
oh wait you're right now i forgot it was raining i forgot it
was raining okay it melts in water by the way and i was like
oh yeah rain prowler's mask backstabbing flicks bleed nail
board wait how much money i have 10 cents dude does my money
does my money come back like do i Pass down my wealth to my
children?
Or like...
Or...
Do I...
Or like...
Do I lose it?
Money does come back?
Okay, rare candy is always worth it?
Okay.
If you make it...
But not in a new...
Yeah, okay.
I was gonna...
I was just wondering, though, like...
Like...
If I go on a new adventure...
Oh, okay.
oh so so if I go on a new adventure um the money doesn't
pass down right or oh it does okay why the fuck did I spend
my money okay
can use consumables gain a half size that has 50 the copy is
AI controlled oh wait but doc okay your base attack has one
plus but deals and the enemy and spawn flee familiars equal
to the numbers of enemies you can okay we'll do a mini me
congratulations doc you are a father we did not neuter you
in time all right can he eat now or no okay you can't all
right all right what's time there's boss fight time the
radical rat boom goes oh no oh no he's so Oh, this is- this
might be trouble.
Meow.
Get closer.
That's right.
So I can beat you up.
Oh, fuck!
That's right.
I should have done that first.
That was my mistake.
What the fuck?
Wait, can I- Can I bat it off?
Oh, nice.
All right, heal yourself, though.
Okay, I can...
I can actually kill the bomb.
That's good.
That's actually really good.
I'm gonna go over here and see if I can...
Fire!
And then...
I can't do anything after that.
Meow.
Alright, lob it.
Okay, you're actually useless!
Yeah!
You're not useless!
He's not useless!
Nice.
Get over here, that's right.
Get hit!
All right, we'll end there in here.
And then...
Oh, shit.
That's five.
Meow.
I hit this?
No.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna bat it.
Get out of here.
Oh, no.
He's so far now.
That sucks.
I have to hop closer.
He's so far from me.
I can't...
Oh, my God.
do anything i'm just gonna do that i'm gonna be small i'm
gonna be tiny
roll over here make it more and then shoot him oh shit
whoops
okay that's awkward is it it's okay my ai's got it my aas
got it oh shit he's not feeling so good the acid rain is not
doing so well for me i will say i will
that's my bad i didn't realize that was a thing i i thought
I thought it was, you know, because it's dead that it like
fully diffused itself But little did I know it's not dead
dead
Wait, is it because of the fire?
I fused oh my god It's the fire, isn't it?
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, it was the fire
Okay, okay This is a sacrifice.
Wait, how much is HP?
Okay, wait.
I swap with you.
And then, there you go.
I'm quick!
Me, meow!
And then...
Hut!
And paw!
Well, what's that over there?
Meet me up.
Oh, wait.
Let's hop over there.
It's catnip.
Let's go.
And then leap.
Oh, wait.
I can't leap this.
Leap!
Boom!
Oh.
Alright, that's fine.
He's okay.
Meow.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, that's so easy.
Meow.
all right your spell costs three mana cast but each cat can
be cast only once per turn over power excess damage you deal
to units makes them explode dealing next to the units around
except for you plus one race for each enemy your basic tacit
grill that hit the front of a unit oh shit yeah like that
we'll grab that all right oh they're locked yeah okay it's
guess it's time to go home okay i made it Guys, I will say I
did pretty good with acid raid as my first run with how fuck
that RNG was on the first run and I still made it home.
Oh, I can now go to the sewers.
I survived.
Good job, my little cat.
Oh, shit, sorry.
There you go.
Go celebrate.
You all deserve it.
All right, guys.
Make me my, make some kittens for me.
There we go.
Yay!
Wait.
Oh, Mr. Bamboo and made another cat.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I wasn't but care.
Oh, no.
She said no.
She said...
He's like, no.
I did not.
She wants a real man.
Oh, it's raining again.
Got friends.
Rain is a spooky one.
I think it rains because we did bad things.
The Rain Man sees what we'd be doing, and he tells on us.
We are Frank, and we live under your house.
Don't keep beating the allegations.
Damn, first run, done.
I don't think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
hear us scratching it gets itchy down here sometimes
sometimes we like being itchy because being itchy makes us
work harder bet you didn't know frank built your house no
lying i don't think i like that frank built my house cough
cough we're just kidding on you but really we love to build
so you want if you're gonna if you're gonna want to have
more houses made just ask frank frank do need to be Kisses
no more.
No, Frank wants friends.
Cat friends!
See that pipe over there?
That pipe goes all over the place.
You want to send a kitty up?
Push him down the pipe and bam, there he goes.
We don't want just any kitty though.
Frank wants retired cats only.
Frank thinks we like retired cats because we are kind of
retired too.
Okay, well, we go night nine.
Alright.
We have Amanda.
Alright, Amanda.
What do you have?
Alright.
Well, let's put Mr. Bam.
Alright, goodbye, Mr. Bamboo.
We lived a good life.
Everybody say goodbye to Mr. Bamboo, guys.
Say goodbye to Mr. Bamboo.
He lived a good life.
Don't worry, his wife can find a new boyfriend.
I believe.
Goodbye, Mr. Bamboo.
An attic.
Oh, I get an attic.
Mr. Bamboo, for what?
other male cats.
was just waiting for you down here.
Good job on sending cat to us.
He's slow so when he runs, we can still get him.
Frank's slow, but no one seems to get us.
Cough, cough.
Frank's getting so itchy.
I think we're ready to build.
You know how it's on top of your house?
The one to point on it?
Well, Frank's going to be building all over that one.
You just wait and see.
It won't crush you or nothing.
Alright.
What is this another tip.
I hear mom say about Frank.
Frank's scabby is just the tip of the iceberg.
We miss her.
Sometimes we look at the stars and talk at her in our
brains.
I wish she could come back.
Okay.
Who's Butch?
Oh, that's the thief.
So check this out.
I got a new caller for you.
This class is called the cleric.
Pretty hoity-toity religious type.
Oh, this is my healer.
cleric on your team ain't no one going down and if someone
does just pray on it okay you realize taking the hard path
down gives you better items but also levels your cat up more
every battle loves a cat and the hard paths all feature an
extra fight that's three more levels you could be gaining
take all three hard paths you don't always need to take the
hard path especially if you're getting trash but you know
what they said no risk no rewards okay i was not taking the
hard path um when it was acid rain Oh, there's Tink.
Well, someone's need of a makeover.
Let's chat.
Yeah, I don't think we would.
That's where I need to put it.
Get a healer cat.
I'm trying to remember which.
Oh, I think the archer cat was pretty useless.
Poops and dead cats actually lower your comfort.
And it's also just really freaking gross.
Watch yourself, girl.
What about another tip?
Oh, my God.
Just notice the shirt he's wearing.
Hold on.
Wait, let me.
I mean, I don't know.
For those who haven't watched people play this game yet.
Appeal makes your house, well, more appealing, I guess.
The higher appeal, the better strays are that appear each
day.
Don't sleep on appeal.
How do I get appeal, though?
Cat lady, and it's a terrible title for this song, which is
otherwise very...
Alright.
Um, I guess we...
Well, we technically...
Oh, we don't have enough cats.
We only have this cat.
All right, end day.
We need four cats.
Oh, with furniture?
Oh, my God.
Zaris doesn't want...
Oh, it's because of his broken rib?
Why won't my cat bang?
Oh, no!
No!
Just because she lost her husband!
She was like, I can be the alpha cat now.
One that was worded plus one archery.
What the fuck?
jinx oh my god what's wrong with you what toast okay oh no
wait what happened to you where's the jinx
wait where's the jinx part maybe they should kill him yeah
what the fuck is this song Wait, Frank needs another cat.
Wait, they want to talk.
Oh, and mine is luck.
What does Butch want?
So it looks like that sewer monster man built you a pipe,
huh?
But don't feel special.
I got one, too.
How about you and I go into this?
You send me cats with combat experience, and I let you kiss
me behind a dumb...
Oh, oh, I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm gonna have to say no on that.
We're, like, in that type of...
Our friendship is not that high yet, bro.
And, you know, you know, they say kiss your homies
goodnight.
But, like, bro, we ain't homies, man.
I just met you.
Yeah, well, but I spanned that litter box of yours.
Talk about that box by your house, sicko.
I can upgrade that old shoe box.
That way you can hold more sharp objects.
Trust me, it's worth it.
Just send me a cat who's killed some stuff and I'll hook you
up.
All right, what does Tink want?
Well, hello there.
You're the talk of the town these days.
Everyone's all like, there goes that so-and-so, aren't they
a catch?
They got brains and buns.
And I'm like, thanks, girl.
But did you hear about the Nubian town who's been hoarding
all those cats?
And then they're all like, yeah, yeah, heard about them.
But what's this I hear about that book deal you landed.
And I'm all like, oh, leave me alone, stalker.
Lull.
And gosh, people today are so nosy, right?
Anyway.
What's this about you and me being pipe buddies?
You know, I can, like, hear you talking your sleeve through
that thing, right?
You old perv.
My wife made me cover the pipe with a quilt.
She was, like, so embarrassed.
girl but listen i need a baby i have this empty hole in my
heart see my wife and i we can't have children of our own so
we had decided to start a cat family and guess who the
father is that's right it's you silly just send your kids
and i'm sure you can find a way to return the favorite but
try not to send any uggles keep your donkey face fuggles in
the basement toodles not yet he doesn't want uggles
apparently all right let's send a kitten over all right
since okay care care up it's actually pretty good so i'm
gonna send i'm gonna send you over actually i wasn't really
a actually let's see doc what was mini me maybe it'll pass
down mini me I don't know who had the worst traits all right
let's see um we gotta pass down we gotta pass this down so
I'll send the new cat I'll send Amanda out we just got her
so like I haven't I haven't like had I haven't had any
attachments yet wait is he not a baby oh my gosh she's not a
baby she's three years old all right never mind I thought,
you know, I thought it was like human three.
Okay, who do we send over to?
I guess Pelin?
I haven't grown attached to her yet.
Oh, wait, she's not retired.
Oh wait.
I mean, she's five.
Oh, who have been on an adventure?
Let's see.
I don't know who I don't like.
Maybe I'm actually send Gambo over.
Only because, like, she was the first cat, but her stats are
pretty shit.
Send the fighter?
They want anyone that's had fighting experience.
I feel like Chando has clutched a lot.
I'm gonna send...
Let's see.
Everyone else has pretty decent stats.
I'm gonna send Gambo out.
She has decent base stats.
Really?
I feel like her base stats was, like, Like, pretty alright.
And, like, Kara was, like, a really good mage.
I'm going to send Gamble over.
Goodbye, Gamble.
The first cats I got.
She's, like, getting old, too.
She got to retire.
Hey, that cat you sent me could really take a punch.
So, um, as per our agreement, I'll upgrade that storage box
of yours.
So pretty tiny, Odyssey.
I got bigger ones, but they will cost you.
Send more cats with fighting space, and I'll expand it more.
This time, though, I want cats that ventured further from
home.
Go any adventures in sewers or junkyard this time.
Good luck.
All right, we got...
All right, let's have them make a baby.
A simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wanted to get it on with Amanda, but Amanda wasn't into it.
No!
again.
I'm sorry.
None of my cats will fuck.
Why would my cats fuck?
I'm sending, alright, you're going into a... Wait, how old
do the cats have to be?
Use the attic?
What do I do with the attic?
Okay.
That's two boys.
Wait, who are my best cats?
Okay, I actually okay your mage was crazy and then okay
that's girl what is your okay we need mage and let's fuck it
let's go let's see if something comes up oh wait the poop
they're like hiding behind all the poop okay truly truly
these cats no luck for pregnant oh shit you're right that
luck is really low I don't know all right how about you two
all right you two this is a match make in heaven yeah what
did you use protection who sneaked plan B to my cats who's
infertile which was the infertile one like Oh my god,
they're two men.
I just noticed they're both men.
I They're both infertile.
I didn't realize I was just looking at stats.
I was like damn, you guys have good stats I didn't realize
you were both you were gay
All right Smooth vibes here on WMW.
All right, we have go bang all right there we go yeah we
made a cat all right what's your stat oh shit you get you
like well luckily I'm sending you over to tank real quick
new cat just thank you the super chat thank you thank you my
little heart is so full thank you thank you knowing how much
this little guy missed us about your payment I'm a bit lost
here um here take this little bow i guess i may seem useless
now but in the right light the color is just to die for
seriously this bow could make god cry don't you there throw
it away you can leave now oh but don't forget to keep
sending me kittens tootums all right nice all right so i
have a new cat all right i should have enough cats now
they're not great cats but i should should have enough.
Alright, there you go.
I have another kid.
Yay!
Oh my god, Kara does not want to.
Oh, no!
Stop fighting!
No!
A broken grip!
Oh my god, all my cats.
All my cats.
It's not going so well.
All my cats are fighting.
Alright.
okay oh their stats are all so bad yeah meow okay this has
all right you should be away are you a kid no you're fine
there's a catastrophe all right we have charisma okay we
have okay we need someone are we need someone that's smart
we Do you have any smart cats?
Oh no, my cats are stupid.
Oh no.
None of my cats are smart.
Oh wait, okay, you're my only hope.
You're actually the smartest one.
All right.
That's fine.
Mow.
All right, this is, we're gonna go now.
Kara is eight.
Yeah, do I, how, when do they die?
Chat.
When do my cats die?
Oh, my cats are a little special.
It's random.
Well, archery.
But actually, those are great at keeping your team alive.
Helping them recover from taking hits.
We should have one.
We should give this to one now.
There we go.
We'll give it to this.
Alright.
And then you.
We do need a tank.
And then.
Plus two.
God.
Mage was so good though.
Uh.
What do I get rid?
Maybe.
Plus two charisma.
Meow.
Maybe I give mage instead of archery.
I didn't like...
I didn't really like archery.
Hunter over a mage?
Yeah.
Really?
I had more luck with mage than I did with hunter.
Is hunter better?
Alright.
Alright, we'll try.
Oh, I got a bow.
It's fancy.
Let's see.
We should give...
the fighter this and then let's see he does look like a mage
though and we'll give the tank bow
now inflicts my basic attack look at that and he could be
really he can be a fancy cat yeah there's more than one way
to skin the cat I don't think I have a bow bow yet.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Yeah, I don't have a bow yet.
I didn't see a bow anywhere.
Alright, let's go in.
Battles start.
Mangy.
What's this?
Cat nip antidote.
Okay, we're gonna chew a melee attack, reduce.
Catapult?
Yeah, Throw one.
We're gonna throw.
Oh, wait.
I can...
I can throw... How do I throw people?
Okay.
I have to wait.
Alright, let's see.
When you damage your account dealing one.
Okay.
I'm gonna go right here.
I'm ready to fight.
Oh, catapult.
Chuck her there!
Yeah!
That's right, get out of here.
Alright.
Nice.
Meow.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of it.
No!
Oh, fuck.
I should not have.
Wait.
Inflict Mark on incoming physical damage has ignores.
Gave it just in unit plus two charge.
Alright, we'll grab the cannon.
Oh my gosh.
She's already fucked up, though.
I'm gonna I'm gonna send this over
Okay Marked That's right, you marked now Okay In my turn Mow
Cleans and Zip are making a cleanse Remove all debuffs,
you're here You're here, you're here, all right come over
here I'm gonna help you I'm gonna get you over Oh my god
you're so far i can't heal you oh no oh my broken rib oh no
oh that's not good
that's actually not good he's gonna i'm gonna kill them real
quick
oh that is not good
Miao!
Put that guy out.
And then...
I'll mark you.
Miao!
Maybe I can heal you.
Don't worry, I'm gonna heal you.
Oh, you're still so far.
You're so far.
Miao!
Alright, we're just gonna and then you know what I'll do
that and then I'm gonna eat you I'm gonna eat you yum yum
okay we might need one of our cats is pretty fucked up
already collect destroy equip piece of cat hide on me set
trap that webs non-bug units shoot a flea at a unit fire
shock likely to ignore shields and cat miss oh yeah i won my
cat i don't think we're we're gonna live this run i think
one yeah for sure yeah our our fighter is not doing so land
and night is pretty messed up right now she uh already has a
broken rib oh no
all right the sky darkens uh forming small paws on ground
wetting the cat's software okay it's not too bad oh it's
raining it's not that bad rain won't hurt us all right oh my
god there's a lot of wait why do they get to move first what
the fuck that's my cleric
wow cleric, what the fuck?
I'm gonna go over here.
Okay.
And I'm gonna relax.
Alright, get out of here!
That's right, run!
Fucking run!
Know what?
I'm gonna eat you.
Um!
That's fucking right.
Bound.
Okay, one, two, three, four, five.
what wait come out reckon you know what I'm good let's check
holy shit what yeah what the fuck happened oh I can
desecrate the corpse okay we gotta heal her I'm healing her
real quick all right and then you're fine
Wow Okay You know what I'm just gonna hit that But I can't
hit it I'm gonna go over here Nice And then
For counterattack And then I'm gonna 50-50 That's right And
I'm gonna hit your corpse I got nothing out of it And then
Can't fall me into the cat!
Me?
Yeah!
Yeah.
I'm gonna test my 50-50.
Punch you into the water!
There you go.
Actually, we'll mark him.
Yeah.
And then...
There we go.
easy oh wait there was a cross here i just noticed that cat
foot cat foot meow i fucking love this triple two towers
straight and destroying any inanimate in three forms the
spells uses your movement jump to a tile mobilize anything
you land on i feel like belly flop right snip is clutch yeah
it's actually clutch triple over two tiles in a straight
line Should I do?
I don't like 4.
4 requires money.
1 or 3?
1?
It's fine.
You guys don't need... The fourth option is always bad,
guys.
It's fine.
I'll do 1.
I feel like the trampling is pretty good.
Spawn 3 at the start.
Alright, I think it should be this guy.
Alright, let's get the chest.
yeah oh my mana leech spawn a leech familiar after every
third spell okay
oh i'll do the coin i think coin is better spare some change
to help my nana i am broke little kid i'm gonna ignore him
surely that's not a beauty in the beast situation, right?
Right, guys?
I'm gonna ignore him.
Yeah, no money for you.
I hope Nana will be okay.
Yeah, no change, guys.
No change.
No money.
No Ablo Angles.
The Mangy Chubbers versus Venier.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
No, not again.
Not again.
Okay, where was it?
It was here, right?
I'll grab this.
God, not again.
Okay.
Alright, there's this here.
Meow.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's so far from me.
He's just running away like a little bitch.
Okay, it's here.
What?
I'm marking him.
Yeah.
Get marked.
I trust this 50-50.
Enter.
Oh, my God.
You fucker.
You actual fucker.
Okay.
I'm going to do this, and I'll kill you.
you there i give you a kiss a little kiss oh my god god i
hate this guy oh my god did he bear trap this i i don't
remember i'm
50 50ing this god damn it
oh my god i'm losing track on all the bear traps there's too
many bear traps guys there's a bear trap right here i
remember okay
there we go you fucker it's okay he smacked me on it oh my
god there's too man he fared yeah that's right
one two oh
boom okay okay bucket here just because i can nice just got
that bear trap
okay we'll hose you off you can you can now Do whatever the
fuck you want.
And then...
I'm just gonna walk over here.
That's on me.
I forgot where the bear trap...
I lost track, guys.
I really did.
There's just too many traps.
There's too many traps.
I'm gonna end my turn.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
Let's get...
I'm belly flopping over there.
Surely there's no trap here.
Get over here.
I'll punch you too.
That's right.
There we go.
It's a trap.
I fell for it again.
Oh my god, pour it again!
Wait.
It's two.
Plus two diminishing.
Ooh, a random stat.
Oh, and plus one to adjacent unit.
wait oh my god wait all i'm born again then you fall asleep
okay wait is that yeah i'm gonna do born again
he does not have guys you don't understand he is actually my
smartest cat of all my cats it's surprising none of them are
inbred but he is surprisingly my smartest cat
My cleric is the smartest cat out of all my cats, guys.
Are you kidding me?
How?
We just got out of the beer trap.
They're all not in bread, though.
None of them are in bread.
Meow.
I'll grab the money.
I don't really care.
Yeah.
I'll mark.
Which one's, like, scarier, I feel like.
I'll do that rat.
Eh.
Oh, I can't mark any of them.
Oh.
I guess I'll just move.
I'll move here.
And then...
Get out of here.
Oh, I should have done a counterattack.
Uh...
I'll heal you.
There you go, a little kiss.
A little kiss.
And...
Yay.
Oh my gosh.
It's alright, he just got a kiss.
That's right, get out of here!
I'll grab you too.
I'm gonna shake you!
And I'm gonna bounce on you!
That's right!
And then...
I'm gonna smack.
Smack.
Oh, he's definitely dead.
Yeah.
All right I don't need to do it, but like Actually, I don't
need to do it, but I want him dead dead I'm securing the
kill chat.
I'm making sure this cat this this fly is dead dead Meow I'm
gonna heal you lick Understandable Oh my god, I'm just a
little I'm just a little meh I really flop on him too There
you go And I'll punch him Yeah Yeah I'm sending a message
Okay nice Netflix burn
Move towards the end Then when you are the father you move
Okay I'm pretty dumb right yeah
And bruise five all right we should get one d chest berserk
is berserk good but like but she's pretty stupid berserk is
good i will get berserk all right yeah sure listen to it oh
she's stupid fuck surely nothing bad's gonna happen oh i
forgot you're pretty stupid Oh, oh, no.
Guys, I don't think I can...
I don't think I can break it, and I don't...
Why did it choose my cleric?
She can't do nothing!
Let's go yamling.
Let's listen to it.
Surely nothing's bad.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Is she schizo now?
What happened?
Wait, what happened to my cat?
Oh, nothing bad happened.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, she's just depressed.
She didn't go schizophrenic.
She's just depressed.
That's, that's, that's okay.
Oh, a human heart.
Nice.
What can I do with that?
Oh, plus two HP.
Oh, wait.
Max health and post-combat.
I feel like...
I feel like my tank, right?
Or maybe, like, her.
Great job, it's now depressed.
Who should I give it to?
Yeah, I feel like my fighter, right?
Because my fighter's pretty shit.
Alright, let's go down.
We got a shop.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I have a rare cat in me.
Let's grab a rare cat in me.
Your base is always critical on enemies that have damaged
you when you're down a unit gain plus two!
Oh!
Wait, infested!
I'm gonna do infested.
Because, like, I have a chance to spawn a flea familiar.
I feel.
Check the weather.
It's raining still.
It's been raining for 20 years.
Frenzy Berserker?
Two is good, too?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's not just rain.
What happened?
Oh, no.
Oh, it replaces a passive.
Oh, I don't know if I like that.
Well, my things don't die, so I'm going to do Avenger.
Wait.
Try it.
Get rid of.
I feel like my cats have been...
Unless we do something else.
infested drop avenger yeah i'm gonna drop avenger all right
here we go all right we'll go go fight oh my god it's
radical rad it's okay we don't have fire no more
okay is everyone healthy i ask
I don't want to Then this a bit becomes a berserker Yeah,
we're gonna wait I wish I had my goat Oh god, I missed Oh my
god Oh my god, that's fucked Yeah, I can punch him though
Get out of here Oh I can't life steal yet.
I'm marking you.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I think I can mark you now.
Get marked.
Me.
Meow.
There you go.
And then I'll give you extra charge.
I'll give you inspiration.
Meow.
Bro, what the fuck?
Okay.
There you go.
I healed you.
But who will heal me?
But why the fuck does he keep throwing?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Why is there a zombie cat?
I want to life steal this.
Om, yom, yom.
And then I'll shake you.
And now punch you.
Oh, because it's raining.
his... Oh, I did not know.
I should...
I did not know that.
Okay.
Bad, bad kitty.
Mark you.
Snipe.
Minus 18.
Now I'm gonna spot...
Oh.
Well, we're... I'm pretty sure the zombie cat's not gonna do
anything to us, right?
I'm just gonna walk away.
Just gonna...
Alright, I'm just gonna walk away.
I'm gonna assume the zombie cat holy shit okay um oh god
there's a lot of zombie cats now there's a lot of oh it's
awkward okay we're gonna try and kill this cat first
okay all right that zombie cat's down
get out of here there we go I sort of wasted that, but I got
scared.
All right.
Holy shit, okay.
Okay, that's unfortunate.
I'm gonna move here.
I'm gonna belly flop on you.
Belly flop!
I'm gonna shank you.
And I'll punch you!
Yeah!
That was the last...
Okay.
Oh my god, nice.
Alice gain all stats up when you kill something.
Oh, wait, that's always good.
Eatings all stats up.
Whenever...
Oh, when I kill something, yeah, she's not killing anything.
All she can do is heal.
When you're down for the first time, each battle takes no
injury.
Revive.
Oh!
And battle with 1 HP, gain plus 1.
When you're down, all allies gain all stats up.
I feel like...
Eternal.
I can go to the sewers.
Wait, if I go to the sewers, do I continue my adventure?
Oh my god, is it worth it?
Guys, is it worth it?
It is raining.
Oh my god, not the zombie.
Is it worth it, guys?
Do it?
Gamba?
Oh my god.
Alright, it's gamba time.
Let's see if my cats return home.
Alright, the sewers we go.
Okay, maybe a large catnip.
Gain plus five for the rest of the battle.
That creates a creep puddle.
I think we can use this.
The mana leech.
Spot on leech familiar.
Wait, is this magic?
This is magic, right?
Gain's a mana at the start.
That is magic, right?
The mark?
Yeah?
Okay.
Because I'm always using mark, so yeah.
All right, here we go.
oh shit what the fuck oh shit what the oh my god what the
fuck is that all right let's go in the water we're gonna
shake you and then wait how much hp do you have left poor um
i'm gonna punch you that's right you want i'm gonna eat you
too yum yum i'm done my turn We'll go here.
And then beat you up.
Get that pipe out of here.
That's right.
Get out of here.
You know what?
I'm a berserk too.
Oh, I can't do anything with my berserk.
I'll just stay here.
Holy shit.
One armor?
Oh, no.
I gotta heal her.
I'm a mark.
Oh.
Move here.
Mark you.
Snipe you.
There we go.
Get out of here.
And then wait my turn.
Bottoms up.
Alright, my mage just gotta give you a kiss.
And then, don't worry.
I'll clean your bruise.
Meow.
And then I'll beat you up.
Get out of here.
And then I'm going to take your money too.
After I'm done.
Berserk into you.
Smash you.
And then saw you.
Yay!
Pet rock.
Rocks you spawn and have plus three.
Spawn a rock at the start of the battle.
Toad style.
Your movement action is a jump.
Landing on a unit deals.
And displaces it.
If you end up battle with 1 HP.
Game plus 1 to a random stat permanently.
Oh, actually.
Plus 25%.
You know what?
I feel like Toad style.
Yeah.
Toad style my tank.
Would be like super strong.
I feel like.
We found.
Looks like in awe.
At the massive defecate.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
I mean he is can he tank it do you think he can tank the
mega huge poop all right I believe in you yeah I got
enchanting poop it's his fill acquire an insatiable appetite
for the peculiar flavor all right what did she get though I
got enchanting poop I got slimy hat too um heal five HP
winning damage at the start of your near You automatically
move towards it.
You don't!
Wait, that's good.
Yeah, she can always heal.
In mobile one, inflate your mobile one units that contact
you.
Cannot move.
I feel like you don't need a move.
I don't know, actually.
He's so hungry.
Oh my god, look.
She'll always...
have heels what the fuck is that boomer oh shit okay i think
she can tank that right oh i'm just gonna jump on this poop
though boom and then
oh i can't do anything after that oh god that's bad that's
bad that it can do that I'm a little scared.
Yeah, they explode.
Yeah, the fact that they explode when they die is making me
a little scared.
What is this?
You know, poor HP went.
I was going to eat that, actually.
I'll wait.
I can wait.
I'll kill Berserk.
And then, um, I'll wait.
Oh my god, there's so much poop.
Can I mark him?
I can mark him.
I'll kill this guy.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, it does friendly fire.
It friendly fires.
That's good.
That's actually pretty good.
And then...
I'll grab this.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
That's fine.
I ate the poop.
And then...
I have to go to her.
Very slowly.
But I can wash the bruise off right now.
Oh, wait.
Everybody is full HP.
That's good.
I will enter in here.
Nice.
Oh, the water does damage.
Okay.
Um.
No, I'm gonna eat you.
I'm gonna eat the poop.
It'll be fine.
Oh, this is bad.
I actually should not be here.
And then...
Oh, no.
I have to get out.
it here for me oh oh nice she booted me away yeah yeah and
then i'll wait actually uh yeah i'll wait here not too
scared of the poop right now so oh man i can't really do
okay i I can't hit that, though.
I shot exactly.
God damn, I forgot to count.
It's fine.
I can mark this.
And then shoot this.
Boom!
And I'll wait here.
And...
I'll just wait here.
I'll just chill here.
Oh, shit, no!
Wait, that's fine.
That should be fine.
And I'll enter.
Meow.
Oh, yeah.
Now beat him up here.
And then, how much HP does he have left?
Now jump away.
Jump.
Wait, I can belly flop?
Oh, I can't belly flop on that.
Can I hit my own teammate?
I wonder.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, I'm too scared to like...
If I hit... Wait, can I... If I... I'm going to experiment.
Oh, shit.
That's okay.
Catapult.
Get me in the money.
Catapult!
Oh, my God.
Another one.
Smack!
Holy shit!
I'm so strong.
Wasn't too bad.
Yeah, it wasn't too bad.
I got a little worried for nothing.
Your base attack inflicts charm the first time.
you use it each battle small enemies adjacent enemies have
allies have oh when enemies come with it shoot them for one
damage i feel like maybe top tower defense or don't tower
defense is crazy two okay we'll go with two all right grab
the chest all right what's in that toilet Slimey mask.
I feel like we're already at Thumb... Oh!
Where's this?
Thumbbell should be plus one.
Meow.
I'll be putting on him.
And then 50% chance to catch for that slimy hat.
I don't know about it.
Okay.
I'm gonna go with that.
Everybody seems okay for now.
Beneath the surface.
Oh shit.
Using item from a back back oh shit i'm sorry bro you're
you're fucked
um he is not prepared for this um which would fuck him the
least guys i feel like diving the boy is gonna die so i'm
gonna do a use it item all right what did he get all right
it's fine we didn't need the slimy mask i was gonna say
there was no items in my backpack That was, like, good.
I already equipped all the good stuff.
I was worried.
Let's go.
100 HP?
Oh, my God.
I'm nervous.
I'm actually nervous.
What the fuck did this guy do?
Okay.
I'm going to wait here until...
So I can...
And then...
I don't know what he does.
I'm really scared.
Oh my god.
None of them is in range.
I'll move here.
I can't do anything.
So I'll wait.
Oh, yum, yum, yum.
How does you...
I'll stay here.
here.
All right, what does he do?
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Belly flop.
Shank.
Oh, it's fine.
That was my last one anyway.
Okay.
My dash is not close enough.
I'm just gonna go here.
And I just gotta wait.
It's fine.
And then...
Meow.
I'll move here.
Marked.
There you go.
18.
Okay.
Enter.
Who is...
is most fucked up right now all right i'm gonna oh i can't
even get close to you to heal you i'm gonna heal you i'll
give you the heals oh no oh no no what the fuck why did she
hit me what what the fuck
Okay, she hit me!
What?
Oh my god, my poor cat.
Oh my god, it's so close.
There we go.
And I can do this again.
I could do it again.
That's right.
Meow.
Are you fucking kidding me?
oh my god i'm so unlucky okay does this hit six snip range i
don't know how to okay which what how many steps should i go
though here or here one two three four five six do you think
i could do it here here right
Oh, nice.
Okay, we're gonna mark you.
Never mind.
We're just gonna do this.
There you go.
Oh, it's fine.
I can just use all of that.
And then... Oh, he's 9 HP.
That's good.
Meow.
I'm gonna get away from her.
I'm coming.
Can I heal myself?
No, I can't.
No!
Oh, shit.
My cats are not doing so well.
It's okay.
I can kill him here.
Okay.
I can't kill him here.
I can move here.
I can berserk here.
I can berserk again.
And then...
He's dead!
Oh, shit.
He's just shit.
Um, never mind.
Now he's dead.
Yay!
All right.
Plus luck affects base, crit and not effects melee attacks,
speed, affects max health, and post combat.
Oh, wait.
That is.
I feel like three or four because she's bad at, she doesn't
have speed.
Speed or uh plus two or full heal speed or strength speed
all right speed
all right
all right oh my gosh okay wait she full healed okay it's
just the archer that's fucked up right now all right that's
fine my my my my healer can heal him up oh another rare
candy let's buy that all right oh I feel like strength,
right?
Strength or...
Luck?
Effects, base, crit chance and all.
Should I do strength or...
Or luck?
Not archery.
I don't think archery matters.
Alright, one.
King's crown.
Oh, yeah, no.
I don't want to lose.
stats after all right let's go in oh another event rumbling
a thunder quickly are you serious again
all right why is it always raining why do i keep getting
rain
oh my god
all right one after each turn there's a chance for a random
lightning strike okay that's cool um blows everything okay
let's go i guess how is there a thunderstorm in the sewer
plus three floater okay oh no all right oh jump on to you
and then he's fucking dies away.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna punch the shit, I guess.
And I'll end turn.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god, tower defense is actually so strong.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he didn't hit me.
That was close.
Okay.
I mean, I could, like, beat him up already.
And then we'll go berserker mode.
And I actually want to grab this coin.
Alright, nice.
We just made it.
Okay, I gotta eat this poop real quick.
And then I have to heal you because you're fucked up right
now.
And I gotta cleanse you.
And then I'm gonna move here because I'm scared.
Meow.
Yeah, I'll mark you.
uh shoot you uh here you go i'm gonna encourage you and now
oh thank god i'm not in the water okay all right it's fine
i've cleansed oh my god it's fine he landed on each other
okay round two me y'all
all right i'll belly flop on you too And I'm going to beat
you up.
Get out of here.
My turn has ended.
And what you're going to do, fight on me?
Okay, yeah, he is.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I'm going to go here.
Berserkle mode.
Oh, fuck, he ran away?
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't expect him to fucking run.
away oh no I want to eat him I no I'll cleanse you I forgot
yeah all right just getting him out of here just because I
can I actually want to grab this money too oh no he's gonna
poison me too isn't he it's fine I have I do not have
cleanse.
Oh my God, that is so scary.
Alright, we can jump on him.
And then belly flop.
And then yay!
Oh, we were so, the lightning struck everything but me.
Thank God.
Oh my God, bro.
My archer cat and my healer cat and my tank cat have all
been like super clutch.
Yeah, Tower defense doing damn good work for sure.
I feel like range, right?
I'm going to do range.
Alright.
Open it up.
Yay!
I've got rage.
Roid rage.
For the rest of the battle.
Well, you don't need that yet.
Oh, wait, what?
Game backflip?
Ooh.
Okay, I'm going to give that to you.
you you were too important oh you got that backflip all
right we're almost at the boss but
callus uh i don't think i had get armor cursed okay that's
bad right don't yeah i was gonna say that feels that looks
really bad I was like, that is not...
What is this?
Oh, Boris!
No.
I forgive you.
He looks very...
Wait, is that Binding of Isaac guy?
Oh my god, 200!
Oh my god, and it's raining!
That's bad.
Oh, shit.
It's gonna life steal real quick.
Oh, God.
yeah get him out of here get him out of here don't move me
into that oh my god i can't even oh this is bad actually
can't get into the water
oh if i go in there i'm gonna get electrocuted is it worth
it guys i think if i go in i'll get go in the water get
electrocuted so i don't know
they're moving to the water okay I'll go here then I'll put
my berserker out now oh what the fuck oh no my tank is stuck
there oh no he's stuck
what oh my god she's in the water I didn't even notice I'm
so stupid I didn't even I'm going in the water, guys.
I'm going to go in the water.
I forgot I made water.
I need to go in the water, guys.
I have to.
It's worth it.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Dash in.
No!
Dash in!
Oh, God.
Oh, no!
She's stuck in the water again!
She can't save them.
Oh, this is so bad.
I'm just gonna stay here.
I-
Oh, no!
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
It's almost done.
I can...
I can life steal.
And then...
We'll beat him up.
It's okay.
We'll go here.
And then...
We're gonna heal.
Meow.
And then we'll wait.
We will wait.
Yeah!
Meow!
We stayed alive.
We did it.
Okay.
You might have a broken rib, but we made it.
No, my archer!
My archer!
See, cost two.
That's fucking me out.
You want that mana region?
For her?
What do I want this for?
Yeah, the archer lived, but he took a mana stat, though.
Oh, it's good for...
Okay, I'll get the mana region.
Well, we get to go home now.
He made it.
She made it home.
We made it home, guys.
I could see our house from here.
Run done.
Now we have the caves.
I mean, we're doing pretty well.
I don't even know if I'm doing well or not.
I feel like I'm doing well.
This is my second run.
See, guys?
People doubted me in tactical roguelikes.
Because I have to think.
I've secretly hidden my power level.
Holy shit, that's a lot of stuff.
Trash.
What do I not want?
I want this.
Team plus.
Brought one.
Me, if they give up five, get the ships, they can thank you.
I told you, I was only acting.
I was only pretending to be dumb.
Let's see it.
I don't know what else I don't need.
It's worn.
Yeah, I'll grab this.
This is already about to break anyway.
Keep talus?
I thought talus is bad.
Give up on consumables?
Which one should I give up on?
Yeah.
Oh, I'll do get rid of catnip.
okay we'll go grab this all right that should be good
yeah all right congratulations everybody you know what we'll
put you here and then okay you're a male all right who's
female male actually thank you for that right thank you
thank you thank you thank you oh my god they were all men Do
I not have women?
Oh my god, my entire army was...
They were all men.
I had no women in my army.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The last squad.
No maidens.
My entire army had no maidens.
Okay.
I do want to make more the archer and the tank.
All right, what have you guys, surely?
Upgrade your item storage.
No girls allowed.
Well, well, well, it looks like you got another collar.
The thief, a personal favorite of mine.
Someone bothering, the thief can stab them in the back.
Need some extra cash?
Well, you know the thief's got sticky fingers.
And don't get me started on quick they are.
only clubhouse just hope the girls don't find out haha all
right let's see all right who do we all right surely like
okay maybe i'll send in another one of the women i'll send
you in surely surely they'll start banging all right let's
go celebrate yeah yeah Oh my god, you never want to bang.
No!
Oh, Kara is gay!
Wait, you're gay?
You're a lesbian?
She never wants...
She only wants to bang the female kids!
That's it.
you're useless to me you're not breeding material
you ain't breeding material i'm sending you down a frank the
girl is a lesbian pipe you go okay we have amanda surely
they'll ping amanda all right crunch who are you this will
kill you if it doesn't gain a plus one all right we're
sending it crunch i'm sorry we're sending you to once are
you not a kid in bro she wants he's gonna he has russian
roulette all right surely yes wow yes finally Alright,
strength?
Wait, who was it?
Was it Casper?
Okay, we have strength?
Who did you get this from?
Okay.
Oh, wait, no, her.
Oh, my God.
I needed you to get heals.
You're useless to me.
I'm sending you over.
Wait, she's...
Wait, actually?
Wait, she has born again, though.
By her constitution, fucking is ass.
And new cat, Manequist?
Spanna coin has spawned a random pickup on a random tab
attacking adjacent Okay, but he did get born again though.
All right, let's let's get another one Warriors not yeah
nothing of none of you guys fought You have like almost no
you might want to go on adventure to fight.
Oh, no, I have too many cats Oh, no, I have too many cats
Oh, Tracy Oh, Tracy
Yeah, yeah, I see you.
I'm Tracy, but I honestly don't feel a word can fully
represent who I am as a person, so don't bother using it.
So you must think you're some type of pet lover?
I assume you identify as a pet lover, but how you carry
yourself.
Well, yeah, I thought so pet lover.
God, that term is so specious.
Even hearing the word pet just make my skin crawl.
I prefer the term.
animal companion.
But personally, I'm going to step beyond loving animals.
In fact, I believe all animals should have the same rights
as us.
If not more.
Even the term pet showcased a bigoted species agenda that
this sick world subscribed to.
And I had my way.
Using that word would be punishable by death.
She looks like she uses Tumblr.
god damn it hello welcome to pmart where love for your pet
is never ending our cat donation center stays open 24 7
every donation of a cat age 5 or older will go directly to
the expansion of this location pmart thanks you for your
patronage and have a blessed day i hate you food food for
everything i mean i money for food i'll grab food i feel
like i need food anyway oh what does frank what frank is
scared the cave are a dark spooky thing frank was dead car
when the plane swarms but don't we we got so smart and build
a new frank out of the old one quite as new right look at
how we can make this one dance he's not dancing cough cough
Frank can't dance like old Frank can, but look again.
Is he doing it?
Oh no, I think Frank has no stamina.
Frank needs a nap.
Frank is me.
Alright.
Okay, we might need another lady cat in there.
Alright, we have enough food for another day.
Wait, god damn it.
Yay!
Got it together?
Oh, shit.
Are we summoning another?
Nice.
Oh, we did it!
Wait.
Nice.
Oh, we did it!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Another one.
Please!
I need...
Oh, my God.
There's too many.
He's not gay.
Meow.
Oh, my God.
No!
Alright, you two, you two might have to go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No!
Okay, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, we gotta split you.
We already have enough cats.
Okay.
Okay, we might have enough cats.
Alright, we gotta send...
Oh, we're sending Shando.
Yeah, you're out of here.
We're donating you.
Stalks a food box.
all right you you're going up too many the pipes is calling
you got two uh helen thank you for entering the pmart kitty
donation center rewards program for your help pmart was
re-home has rehomed your donated feline to a family and me
as you may have heard all reward members gain access to
exclusive imports come back tomorrow i haven't restored
restocked any new imports pretty sure it's some kind of
frozen food locker or something hug all right we're gonna
have to food again.
And buy food again.
And then we're going to go back.
And then we are going to... Who was the other cat that got
in a fight?
Landon?
Alright, what are you?
Landon, you're just stupid as hell, but that's fine.
Alright, I'm going to...
Deb?
Alright, I'm going to... I have enough.
No, I still have enough, guys.
I'm going to wait for all my cats to grow up and I'm going
to pick a cat.
Alright.
Oh, oh, no.
Okay, it's okay.
They're making babies.
No!
There were no winners.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I...
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm gonna go buy one more...
I thought I had enough food.
I forgot how many cats I had.
I lost track!
There's so many cats!
Okay.
I lost track!
I have...
18 cats?
Oh my god, there's too many cats.
Oh my god, there's way too many cats, guys.
That's not enough.
Okay, wait, I can buy more food.
Wait, I have enough for another.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, oh my god, I am the crazy cat lady.
I...
Okay, we have strength.
You can be the fighter.
We need some cat.
Oh my god, too many cats.
I actually do have too many cats.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's too many.
Wait, okay.
Okay, um, I'm gonna put all the retired.
I need, I can't.
There's too many cats.
All right, all the retired cats, you go up here.
I'm having trouble keeping track of all these cats.
Okay.
You got speed and luck.
I'm sending you in.
Wait, actually, speed and luck?
Okay.
Does sneak peek to your future donkey?
No!
Alright, you go up here.
I'm trying to figure out what cat to send out.
There's too many.
I'm losing track.
They're all blurring to get it.
the cats are blurring together okay wait this cat is good
wait six luck six okay send her here where's the cow with
six okay there you go there we go all right we depart oh my
god this this is too many cats i can't i can't keep track of
all these cats Wait, is thief good or not, guys?
The Constitution.
Okay, that should be...
We should have...
But now, it's I...
Not really.
Then I was going to do, like...
Oh, I'm going to do...
Okay, you can be tank.
Ten charisma.
Ah, meow.
Wow.
You're already stupid, so it's five.
Okay, you should get archery.
Wait, six archery.
You already have good speed, though.
Minus one constitution.
Maybe you?
Actually?
That's really good speed, though.
Should I give it to Miffy or Manikin, guys?
12 HP is awful, yeah.
Maybe I should, I'll give it to Manikin, maybe.
Maybe for Manikin, and then...
Let's see.
Plus one speed.
Miffy could be a good thief.
Yeah, but we need a cleric.
Wait, oh, we have Born Again.
cleric.
Yeah, you're my cleric.
I forgot you have four and again.
Oh my god, I forgot to look at my stacks.
Okay, push attack.
To spawn a random pickup on the random tile.
Block, short.
Stop.
Alright, you get fighter.
Or a mage.
I make them a thief?
Oh my god, I made them a thief.
Oh my god, where are you?
There you go.
Okay.
all right i think that's good not smart enough he's he's
five intelligence is five it's fine it's fine melee low hp
it's fine he's he'll be okay he'll be fine he'll be okay
that's true they are pretty dumb but but like they're my
special little kiddies I don't remember what's...
Oh, a leech for him.
Shoot a flea at a unit.
Hunter.
Love.
Okay, make a wish.
Okay, you as a fighter.
Um, I don't remember what I gave.
Human heart was...
Her, right?
Okay, and then cleric, I gave the shit ability.
And then him, I gave the dumbbell.
There we go.
What did I gave the hunter?
Oh, the money.
Oh, wait, no.
The disc.
There we go.
I need the backflip.
And then...
Oh.
Okay, yeah, this is gonna break for sure.
I gave you the pipe.
And then...
I think I gave you the...
What did I give you?
What do I give the callus to?
Chat?
Yeah, but who do I give it to?
On the cleric?
Can be nice on the hunter?
Do I give it to the...
The fight?
Oh, I don't have an armor item, though.
That's the thing.
I don't have an item that gives me armor.
Are you most vulnerable?
I guess the cleric, right?
Oh, wait until you have an armor item?
Oh,
it starts...
that two by default okay it gives plus two oh i don't know
then inflicts rot one oh we'll always crit against this wait
that's actually pretty good i should give this yeah my cats
aren't looking great they're pretty special this cat has uh
four eyelashes Archer is good.
Alright.
I'm going to give him callous.
Here we go.
Oh shit.
He's fucked.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my gosh.
My cat is not looking too good.
Alright, let's go.
Oh no.
I feel like...
This cat's already like...
He's too close.
All right, we're gonna...
We're just gonna hammer these cats.
Get out of here.
Holy shit!
Okay, we gotta hope that he doesn't go into this cat.
Wow!
Team plus one luck?
How do I get out of that though?
Yeah, lucky.
There we go.
Enter.
Oh, more crit chance.
Oh, I see.
Because I was, like, wondering what it does.
Oh, my God.
Cat caller.
Does it call more cats?
Oh, no.
I just don't worry.
I got to eat my shit, though.
Chigo.
Wait, a dash attack equal to the amount HP you healed other.
Oh, okay.
Um.
Oh, she slows my cats.
Okay.
I'm going to do this here.
and then we're gonna spawn a random pickup on yeah let's
fuck it make a wish what did I get game plus two lob shot
and we're gonna lob a shot oh and move here and lob a shot
to this guy boom and shoot a flea at a unit what does it do
what does the flea do or shoot the flea at the poop
go flea go oh shit wait that's that's not a good character
is that gonna hit me I gotta get this guys out of here wait
is that is that mine oh that's mine what is that how did
that get here oh I know but I was like, how did that guy get
here?
I got confused.
Lock.
I don't know how he got here, so I got confused.
Oh, oh, that's the rod.
Oh, okay.
Okay, that makes sense.
I'll grab the coins.
And then we'll see how it goes.
All right, flip.
Yeah, money.
Okay, I have to go here.
Alright.
Boom.
I'm gonna shoot another Flea.
Go, Flea!
Go!
I can shoot another.
And another one!
Get my coin!
Oh, he doesn't pick up money.
That's unlucky.
Oh, goodbye, Flea.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, I have so many minions.
I missed my mobile tank, though.
He's not mobile at all.
There you go.
I gotta destroy this.
Holy shit, how much?
How much HP does this trash bag have?
I have to kill this cat.
I'm just gonna grab the money.
Fuck this.
make a wish
oh no I can't do shit oh no okay it's fine he just hits the
cleric
god I can't go anywhere
I'm so slow no no okay thank god it's just a cleric okay
okay that's good that's good I got a little scared.
I thank God I can actually move now.
Okay, but I really do want to pick up this money.
Okay, the other guy can pick it up for me.
There we go.
I was worried that he was going to hit him.
Alright, make a wish!
Keep making wishes!
Chuck another flee!
Okay, eventually they're going to head there.
Alright, now I'm going to grab the money and do more luck.
I'm just going to be more lucky.
I'm almost there.
Yay!
He exploded!
Oh, he ran away.
That's right.
Run!
Alright, knock back, then dash forward and attack it.
Assert dominance.
If this, you become the Eviro Alpha, this spell deals five
additional.
it plus four and confusion a weak me okay guys the smack is
bad i feel like ram right
a certain dominance
ram is i feel like ram is pretty good so much plus save some
for me jen thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i feel it's either ram or alpha i'll do ram If this kills,
you become...
If your alpha spell deals five additional damage, it
inflicts bruise.
Yeah, I feel like Ram will be useful.
I'm gonna grab that.
Oh, nice.
I'm casting plus three charge.
Wait, can I...
No, I feel like Rot was so OP.
My casts are not as good.
Pull out the knife.
Let's fucking do it.
You're so strong.
You're not so strong.
No!
You're bleeding!
Oh, no!
I don't have cleanse!
This is bad.
I actually don't have cleanse.
Guys, this might be the first run that we're GGs.
I don't have anything.
I'm not that.
Apparently, I wasn't as strong as I thought.
I thought I was so strong.
Okay.
I am a little scared.
Okay, I'll go here and just start healing.
Here, here's a lick.
There you go.
I am a little scared here.
hope that he doesn't come near me.
Oh god.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Only her.
Okay, he can only move one.
Tom Thomas, very weak.
Mao.
I'll get rid of... I'm gonna get rid of you first.
And then...
I'll get rid of you.
I'm gonna go Ram Yield!
That's right!
Get out of here.
And I'm gonna go here, too.
Oh, I definitely need a healer, though.
Eventually, I feel like I will make it across.
I...
Be lucky.
Don't worry.
I have luck.
Okay, I'm gonna slowly walk over to...
Okay, um...
Well...
I said slowly.
I just say slowly, guys.
We're going to shoot the fleet over here.
And then...
Okay.
And then lob it.
There we go.
No!
Okay.
How did it jump to me?
That was so bullshit.
Okay.
Get out of here!
Fuck you.
Okay.
Get this guy out of here.
Well.
All right, finally I'm here.
That took so long.
Finally here.
All right.
Okay, I'm gonna heal.
Heal you.
Lick.
And then we're going to chill.
More money.
Alright.
We're going to be here.
Then we're going to lob a flea over here.
That's fine.
Okay.
He's getting beat up.
But that's okay.
He's a tank for a reason, guys.
Oh my god.
And he's bleeding.
It's okay.
He's like.
tank for a reason guys there
you go nice minus 14 let's go
all right life steal nice there you go in four rounds nice
we got food too all right run next to the ally the most
missing champo all all in the way heal an adjacent unit Cure
wounds.
Target area at the beginning of your next turn.
Heal all units.
Oh, shit.
Metabolize.
Wait, is that permanent?
Is this permanent or no?
Chat.
No, that's where...
Okay, which is better?
Emergency?
I feel like it's not emergency or wish, right?
Oh, it's for the battle.
Cure wounds?
Wish seems good.
Yeah, heal.
Oh, you sound strong.
Okay.
What do you wish?
I'm not fan of my current cats.
current cats are not as good as I like.
I will have to say.
Oh, it heals enemies too?
Okay.
That's a little unlucky.
Pain's slow.
Okay.
All right.
That's where does it go?
Does it go here?
Oh, it goes here.
Yeah, we're not using that.
Okay.
Examine.
Or pick.
Lit it's jar.
Search luck.
I guess pick.
No!
Net poison too!
What?
Yeah.
Oh, my.
this thing oh my god oh my god he has an eagle now
this is i'm gonna do this bash this eagle oh my god it
counter attacks that's
Okay.
All right, I have to do a little flip.
I already forgot where the bear traps are, guys.
I don't remember.
Oh, shit.
Damage will...
Okay.
All right, heal him.
But...
What's going on?
Okay.
Oh, next turn.
Oh, okay.
Shirley's not gonna walk over there.
Oh my god, please.
Alright.
Please, I don't remember.
Okay.
No!
Oh god, not another bear trap.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Oh my god, get healed already!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's awkward.
That's...
Guys, is this...
Is this a bear trap?
I don't remember.
Guys, is this a bear trap?
Before I go in.
Okay, it's safe.
okay that's fine i trust oh my god is that ak-47 what the
fuck was that
no oh nice oh my god not nice
okay there might be a bear trap i knew it i fucking knew it
i'm gonna life steal you and your heels i fucking knew it
how is he still okay there you go there you go i don't know
where okay 11 okay let's hope i can get another wish here
and then i'm just gonna chill
oh my god it's just all bear traps it's actually just it's
all bear traps It's just all bear traps.
Oh my god.
I'm standing on this.
There's so many bear traps.
I'm...
No!
I flee!
Give that shit out of here.
I can't do anything.
I gotta wait.
I block.
Oh my god.
There's so many traps around me.
Oh, miss.
Nice.
Oh, I'm immobile.
No!
Oh, my God.
There's another trap.
Oh, nice.
The flee.
Yeah!
Okay, if I put it, like, here.
Put it here.
And I'm ending my turn.
Okay.
And then there's another bear trap somewhere here.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna shoot a fleet.
Please shot.
I'm pretty sure there's another...
Oh, shit.
That's a half.
Guys, this might be...
This might be the worst run yet.
This actually might be the worst run.
You can't go anywhere though Bear trap Oh my god why Oh my
god
Okay Luck I'm coming over I'm coming over
boom oh my god another bear trap oh when will it end
that's so many traps
like i can't even hit him
i'm going in oh my god there's a trap here Oh my god, this
fucker.
There's a trap here.
Oh my god.
I can't even rap.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where can I go?
Give
me that.
Bam!
Oh, fuck you.
Oh my god, okay, he didn't.
That's okay.
He didn't.
He didn't, he didn't, he didn't fuck me over with this.
Remyiao.
Okay, let's hope that he doesn't heal him.
Oh my god, all he keeps just running away.
He keeps running away and throwing more traps.
Like, I don't know what to do.
Like,
okay.
I can throw a flee and then it missed, but I can also, Do
this.
No, we're so cooked.
We're so cooked.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm immobile.
Immobile.
I'm immobile right now.
Oh my god, it's just traps there.
Yay!
Oh my god, he missed!
Not yet.
Oh my god, there's another trap.
Okay, he healed, but like, oh my god, I should have healed
you.
I should have healed you.
Maybe I can get closer.
There's a trap here, isn't it?
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Oh my god.
Stop.
It's okay.
Yeah!
No!
I'm more guns.
Okay, at least it's not that close to me.
Okay, you just chill.
You have to chill.
Like, you can't go anywhere.
You're, like, trapped here.
Me too.
Same.
Oh my god, it won't...
I can't do anything because like...
I can't... I want him to go down, up and then down!
Oh my god, this is the best I could do.
Oh my god, oh my god, he trapped there.
He fucking trapped there.
Don't worry.
I'm in mobile, but don't worry.
Get out of here!
here.
Okay.
What?
What HP?
How?
Oh my god.
I can't even get to him.
There's a trap right here.
There's...
Okay, it's okay.
All traps.
It's just all traps.
It's just...
Okay.
I can't even ram into him.
I can't...
Please shot!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Alright.
An attack that hits all units.
Okay, we're gonna get Stakeout.
I think Stakeout.
It's over.
It's actually over.
Is that...
holy fuck yeah we're not doing hard my cats will not survive
this this is my worst set of cats harder fights
okay what's better i feel like he'd be poop right poop wow
yeah i got a snack yeah i know my gang these these cats are
cooked these cats aren't for this.
These cats are actually not made for this.
Alright.
Oh, he ran like a little bitch.
Meow!
Alright.
Let's grab this.
Let's get some luck in.
And then I'm gonna go here and then wish ourselves to
full...
I need to wish myself to full HP.
right now.
And then, we're gonna wait.
On your next turn, you're...
Lob shot.
Uh...
Take care.
Nice.
And then we're gonna flee shot this.
Go, flee!
Go!
I believe!
Alright, goodbye!
I- clearly I didn't believe hard enough.
Unfortunately.
Mow.
I'm going to focus on killing these cat.
Bye, cat.
That's right, run!
Well, I can't do any.
I should have just rammed it.
Alright, and then...
Let's beat this cat up.
You know what?
Fuck it, let's go over here.
I'm healed.
Wow.
He's full of HP, right?
We'll go here.
We'll flee shot him.
And then we'll shoot another.
There we go.
That's why I like...
Oh, and then another flee shot.
Double flee shot.
That's what I like to see!
Alright.
Meow.
Round three.
Alright, let's just hit this cat.
And then grab his shit.
And then steal his money.
There we go.
Alright, I'm pretty sure all my fleas can kill him.
Yay!
Oh, shit, there's a maggot.
What the fuck?
Oh, I did not see the maggot.
all right we'll grab this then
all right the maggots should get closer this run might be
safe no i think it's hopeless i think this run is is ggs i
really i do not believe in this run guys my my team this my
team is pretty fucking weak right now yeah when we fight
bosses it's cooked The bosses are just too bad, too, too
strong.
But you need to spawn scrap to pick up or jump up them.
I feel like flip-flop.
The mobility.
No, the...
Oh, yeah, the...
I forgot about the gun.
Should I get flip-flop or a Fisher or throw a scrap?
No, I'm a cat, too.
They're all ugly, but...
But they're doing their job.
Not the best type of job, but they're doing it.
I feel like flip-flop, right?
Damage a lot.
Is that a lot?
Yeah.
Good for your callus.
Yeah, but it's just for a hunter, though.
Uh.
Put all-you-know-why line towards the center of that line.
This has 10%.
Total-not-feature cat lady burden-joined game about cats i
got too many cats i have 20 cats guys i have i fucked up i
looked away for one second now i have 20 cats guys i i don't
know what happened fisher then i'll do fisher i don't know
what happened i looked away and then i have i have five cats
i have 20 cats i should give Maybe I should give...
Actually, do I give it to my...
I should give it to my tank.
Right?
Because the cat...
Yeah, I'm gonna give it to the tank.
I'm gonna give it to the...
Her tank is the one that's going up the most.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Doesn't matter.
Oh, my God.
He's fucked.
Oh, no!
Some of their food in the chaos.
Mac has stored one food.
Madigan!
It's okay.
Madigan, how could you do this?
Oh, propeller hat!
Flying.
Blocks.
Wait.
I can fly.
Blocks incoming ignores tiles and can pass- Oh, yeah!
Wait, should it?
Blocks incoming damage.
Should I give it to him?
mannequin or should I give it my hunter or my my fighter
their OP we'll do it for boss fights though more scaling
okay we'll give it more for fighter or tank I feel like the
tank should have it right should my tank have it should my
tank have it Yeah, I'm gonna give it to my tank.
Alright, I'm broke.
I spent it all on the wishing well.
I...
Whoops.
That's my bad.
I'll put that.
If it's all stats up, then my strength will go up too.
I'll put it here and then...
It's time for a rat, man.
We're going home, straight home.
I am not a fan of my cats.
I, my cats, my cats are not too great.
We're going straight home.
Oh, no.
I need one right now.
Uh...
This is bad Because I don't Oh this is bad
Go here Oh shit That's a lot of bombs Okay at best I can get
rid of this bomb I cannot get rid of this bomb Okay, I can
get rid of one bomb, but I don't know about this bomb.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's not good.
That was not good.
I'm gonna grab this.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Fired.
That's not good.
But I need to get rid of this bomb.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
This thing.
I can go here.
Oh my god
Okay I can't shoot the flea And just pray
Oh this is so bad Oh
Okay, we could do that.
It hurt myself, but it did something.
Pew, pew, pew.
All right.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh, he's just dead.
Born again.
oh no oh no he's oh no okay
I have to go here I'll shoot this cuz he's asleep and then I
have to yes okay okay okay that's five now okay okay okay oh
fuck I'm on fire but it's okay i get two hits there it's all
right that's the risk i'm willing to take oh my god he's
asleep again oh no
oh no i can't oh my god i can't do anything about it okay
holy shit oh my god he's still asleep he's still asleep
I have to get rid of him.
Okay, no Bob.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm fine with taking a little bit of fire.
Fire!
Claw!
Zock.
Okay.
He's on fire.
That's good.
And I will also be on fire.
But I got... Gun!
Holy shit.
He's still asleep.
My cleric has been asleep the entire time.
Oh my god.
I don't even know.
We're going home, cats.
We're going home.
Yes.
cats you I'm sending you all to the pound I'm sorry I think
no no you could have not you no no you could have not my
fellow cats here we are it's warred though I don't know it's
it's almost I like the propeller hat okay we're getting rid
of enchanting poop I don't think we need I like the dumbbell
Crash camp, race for blood?
Oh shit.
Wait, that shit looks strong.
We don't need catnip, I feel.
I'll grab that.
Small bomb, conductor, brain candy.
And now I'll throw everything else away.
For his neutral special, the cat pulled out a gun.
Alright.
Where items are super rare?
Yeah, but some of these aren't even like all right let's see
i think these are all good we're good all right i hate all
of you
we're sending you all we're sending you a frank wait
actually all right let me remember wait he has the callus so
i have to keep you because you have the callus on Wait,
actually.
I'll tell you, I'll give you the five gift of chips.
Thank you.
You guys were all terrible.
You guys were all terrible cats.
I might keep you because you have flea shot.
You might, you get to bang.
All right.
The rest of you.
You're going out.
I'm sorry.
You guys were all, oh, Calus is not inheritable.
All right, goodbye.
No, but the flea shot, I will say.
the flea shot was clutch.
I will keep the flea shot.
Everyone else, you're going to Frank.
Goodbye.
All of you.
The flea shot saved the run.
The rest of you, you're out.
You're out.
All right, I gotta start weeding out some shitty cats.
I have way too many cats.
The good cats are at the top.
The bad, I'm gonna start weeding out the cats now.
Alright, you're going out.
I'm going to send you to Kmart.
Anya.
Anya, get rid of these cats.
Alright.
Strength.
Speed.
You're fine.
I have too many cats, guys.
There's actually too many cats.
Alright.
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
Cat is fucked.
Yeah, I know you're out.
Oh my god, no one wants you.
Why does no one want this cat?
I can't even.
Oh my god, you're too old.
You're too young.
I actually have to keep you.
Meow.
I don't know who to get rid of.
rid of.
Oh my, all these cats are pretty neat.
Are you Rhea?
I'm going to throw you away.
I don't care.
Yeah, I know you're going away.
It doesn't matter.
I'm just going to buy.
I flushed him down the toilet.
Alright.
Okay, I do want a solid tent.
I, you know, I'll keep 14 cats.
14 cats is okay.
It's not that bad.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god.
No!
Okay, there are no winners.
Hey, dude.
I was looking in your windows and seeing you got lots of
cool junk in there.
Oh, me.
I'm baby Jack.
At least that's what the people around me call me.
My Nana says it's because of how talented I am.
I'm a superhero, you know.
Now I also say good boys do nice things, so I gotta get for
you.
Well, I just just gave you.
That's what rich people call furniture.
Furniture around these parts is filled with Jesus juice, but
we can talk about that later.
See that tab up there?
Check it.
Then you can fill your house with all kind of junk.
Okay.
I'll be with Nona in my little shack.
See ya.
Oh, I got soda cans.
I'll put it here.
I guess it looks a little nicer, right?
The soda can?
Alright, Tristan.
I mean, you ain't too bad.
You're left Oh my god, you are a scary cat.
Oh my god, you are a very scary cat.
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
All my cats suck.
Okay, wait, I'm gonna talk to Jack Shack.
Let me go to Jack.
Oh, this is sad.
Oh, hey, it's you.
I was just telling my Nana about you.
She thinks you're nice.
I think she's right.
The other day, I done a kick so hard It made all the Nona's
treasures fall down She's been stuck back there for like
tons of days now But I'm working Oh, I don't think he knows
Nona's dead I bet if I can sell all the stuff that fell down
here I can save her And buy a rocket to the moon Or even a
truck to the park So I need your help Buy my treasures and
help me Bro, $200 They believe said me cats are all broke up
Smash head, bricky bones I need cats like that tell you why
later it's a secret i just made up see ya bro why the fuck
do you need 200 do you want to save your fucking grandma or
not like all right guys i don't really want to do another
expedition only because all my cats suck so i think it's a
good time to call it my cats wouldn't fuck i don't know what
to do and I'm broke and I have too many cats and I have not
enough food.
I don't know what to do.
Guys, how can I fix this problem?
My budget is like this.
One dollar for furniture.
Fifty cents for gas bills.
Three dollars for lights five hundred dollars on cats um and
then four dollars on on cat
and then four dollars on water guys how do i fix this how do
i fix my budget less cats i don't that that seems impossible
guys i i don't know i don't know that i don't think that's
the i don't think i don't think you know what the what the
solution is guys i don't think you're oh my god anyway but
it was it was fun though i actually i really enjoyed the
game i didn't have a i didn't lose a run yet surprisingly i
made it all to the sewers i mean i did three runs the third
one was garbage though my cat sucks yeah serious answers
only i don't to get rid of my cats but guys I'm not here to
fuck around
anyway guys that's fun though it was a game that normally
the type of genre I don't really play but I actually quite
enjoyed this game I really like the rogue like features I
can't believe how unlucky my runs have been but yet somehow
we still make it through every time the fact that we had
rainstorm thunderstorm zombie rain acid rain and yet we made
it that's all that matters we still made it hey guys
tomorrow we're gonna finally complete god of war it might be
an eight plus hour stream guys uh because we're counting
doki hours so if you're if you have a free whole day that's
free tomorrow um we will be attempting to complete god of
war ragnarok hey guys as always everybody say hi drain it
posture flooring.
If you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.